hey everyone my name is Jake I'm gonna
try to explain the combat mechanics of
Xenoblade Chronicles to this game throws
a lot at you so it's easy to lose track
of different things we're gonna start
with a character screen though so when
you click on here basically this is your
party management as you can see each
screen has a driver and their blades you
can click on any of them we're gonna
we're gonna start with Rex who's a
driver and first thing you'll see is
enhanced arts these are basically this
is how you improve your arts which are
moves basically tied to different
weapons as you can see it takes weapon
points in order to upgrade these and the
way you get weapon points is by using
that specific weapon and it's also
important to note that the these skills
that you upgrade carry across carry
across other blades with the same weapon
so if you invest heavily in a knuckle
claws any blade that Rex uses with
knuckle claws will already have these
upgrades as is and as you can see weapon
points are tied a different weapon so
you can't use some for you you can't use
weapon points from your Aegis sword to
your knuckle claws we're gonna skip
engage blades that's basically just
which blades you want equipped it's
pretty self-explanatory Nexus affinity
chart this is a pretty standard skill
tree basically you unlock new perks and
skills with skill points you can see
that down in the corner yeah just come
back here occasionally with all your
with each character and make sure you're
on top of this because it can definitely
help especially later in the game or if
you get if you if you hit a wall next we
have accessories once again pretty basic
I don't think I need to say much about
this it's basically just equipping armor
bracelets whatever and finally you have
pouch setup and now basically what
pouches are they are consumable items
that give you passive skills so for
example the oyster stir-fry gives you -
for other damage for a duration of 20
minutes now it's also important to note
that this duration is only in battle so
it doesn't count down or you're outside
of battle and this is something that I
don't I don't use a whole lot yet but
it's something that you will need to be
paying attention to the later you get
because some of these these consumables
can really help you out so that is
basically wrecks but now obviously we've
got all these plays that you can
customise and upgrade so we'll take a
look at Cora and Cora has there's not as
many menus but it's still important to
look at weapon modification this
basically improves the weapon it's
something that you just want to stay on
top of maybe buy some of these when you
get to stores whatever just they can
vastly improve weapons next up is the
blade skill tree and as you can see this
is a little bit more complex and there's
one big difference between this and the
driver skill tree so instead of using
skill points in order to unlock new
skills you have to come you have to
complete certain challenges so as you
can see here in order to do this one I
need to defeat two more bunun enemies in
Uriah once I do that I'll unlock it
however something very important to
point out is that you need to keep
coming back to this screen because it'll
unlock new rows as you complete other
ones and if you don't do it even if you
complete these different conditions like
I've killed more than enough of those
bonne 'its but since I didn't go to the
screen and unlock the one before it or
since I didn't go to the screen and open
it up then it didn't count so basically
you don't have to do much just make sure
to come back here and keep making sure
you're seeing these things unlock as you
go and finally is the ox crystal so this
is similar to accessories as you saw
with the driver however the big
difference here is that in order to use
these they need to be refined and the
way you refine an ox core is you have to
go to a certain vendor and towns and
basically he'll ask for items and use
those items to refine it and obviously
you've got the same exact setup for all
of your drivers so make sure to stay on
top of this there is a lot of managing
between different characters but it's
very important to be checking up on this
regularly but now that we have that out
of the way I can go to combat and I can
show you some of the basics and how to
do chain attacks which are basically the
way you deal high amounts of damage in
xenoblade chronicles - alright so we're
now engaged in combat one thing to point
out is that I'm not actually hitting
anything your characters will auto
attack and as you can see as I attack
I'm filling up these gauges in the
corner so once I fill one I can hit the
corresponding button
and I will do that move now as you can
tell I'm building up this gauge over
here - with each special I use or with
each art I use so now it's at one once
you're ready to use it you just today
and there we go alright so I'm gonna
stop this through the power of editing
and as you can see in the top right
corner we have a list of moves in
symbols basically these are paths to
different combos so if I want to do Co
blow down I need to use an 11-1 electric
special a level to fire special and a
level 3 wind special or I can do a level
1 Electric special at level 2 Electric
special and then a level 3 water special
we're gonna do that we're gonna do seal
stench combo now that I've done the
first one I need to work up my meter
till I need to work up my special meter
to level 2 and then I need to hit this
monster again after I do that I'll need
a trigger Nia to use her water special
in order to carry out the combo I'm
gonna let the gameplay roll now but make
sure to watch the combos in the top
right corner watch my arts in the bottom
right corner and keep an eye on this
gauge in the top left corner in order to
do a chain combo this needs to be full
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so we've now activated chain attack
these chain attacks basically let you
attack with one blade from each of your
drivers normally they only get to go
once however because we carried out that
combo earlier you might notice this blue
little orb underneath his name now if we
break that orb all of my characters get
to go again
so essentially what you want to do is
try to build up as many orbs on enemies
as you can and use your chain attack
when you use your chain attack you try
to burst all of these in in theory you
can continue attacking for a very long
time
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
so anyway I hope that helped I know
there's a ton of information here and it
can be quite overwhelming but if you
have any more questions feel free to
reach out to me on Twitter you can find
me at Jacob deck or leave or leave
question in the comments below if this
didn't help let me know why is there
something I missed
is there an easier way I could have
explained something just leave that in
the comments as well I'm sure it'll help
other people who decide to take a look
at this video thank you for watching
you